Hello everybody, hello, hello.
Oh, 1230 Street.
Oh, wait, you're not alive on my screen.
Give me a sec.
You're not alive.
I can fix you.
I can always fix you.
Alright, there we go.
Now you're alive.
Hello, everybody.
I am... I'm a little dead inside.
Cause like, for those who don't know, 1230 is Doki's dead hour.
It's me waiting to wake up hours.
Oh my god, I am not a normal person.
I'm not a morning person at all.
Alright, life update.
Wow, Doki.
We had like one plus hour of life update yesterday.
What do you mean there's more?
More stuff happened.
So, no, it's just a tiny life update.
So, the last like month and a half, I've been wondering why is it so cold like lately?
Like, why has it been so cold lately in my apartment?
Cause I was so confused.
I was like, this is weird.
Like, this shouldn't be this cold because I have a heater, right?
And like, it's at... and then it's been... I've been increasing the temperature like every other day.
So, it was at 36 degrees Celsius, like the temperature that I increased it to.
But it was still cold.
So, I was like... like, it was just like a bit cold.
So, I was like, do I have windows open?
I was very confused.
And for those who... for you Americans who are like, the fuck is Celsius?
Okay, 36 Celsius to Fahrenheit.
That is 96.8 Fahrenheit.
So, I was very confused.
Like, why is it cold?
And then, I looked at my... the temperature thing, the temperature button thing.
And I was like, there's something wrong.
And I looked at it.
And then, I was like, wait a minute.
Why does it say cooling?
And then, I was like, wait, there's modes on this.
There's... there's modes.
So, I clicked on the mode and it changed the heat.
So, I found out that for a month and a half, when it was... when I was increasing the temperature, I was actually using the air conditioning instead of the heater.
So, I was accidentally... that's... that's why it felt cold.
It was just blowing cold air, even though it was supposed to be at like 36 degrees.
It was blowing cold air.
So, that's why I was like, oh, so that's why I was feeling cold.
No wonder.
So, now, I didn't put it... obviously, I didn't put it at 36 degrees for heating.
I turned it down after that because I was like, oh, I fixed the problem.
I was like, oh, my God, I finally fixed the problem.
I don't need it at 36 degrees.
Anyway, so, yeah, I was like, okay, I'm going to fix it.
I figured out why my apartment felt cold because I've been on cooling this entire time.
I had air conditioning on this entire time.
So, now, I'm okay now.
Now, everything is okay, chat.
Everything is all right.
So, I've been playing Deadlock on and off and like...
I was playing with my friends and like, apparently, now, I took a little break, but I went back to play Deadlock a little bit yesterday.
And apparently, now, there's no rank anymore.
So, you can get your rank by playing Quick Play.
So, I thought that was really funny because they were like, oh, what's your rank, Doki?
And I was like, oh, I don't know yet.
Like, I have to play one more game.
And after I play one more game, my rank was about the same rank as my friends.
And they were so mad and annoyed because they play so much more than me.
They're like, shut the fuck up, chat.
I was like, oh, hey, what's your rank?
Because I barely play the game.
And then, um, um, and then, their rank was a missionary or whatever.
Oh my god, emissary.
I don't fucking know.
And apparently, that's like plat slash diamond.
And then, my friends were like really tilted because I barely play the game.
And I'm in their elo.
So, I was like, yay, we're the same, guys.
And they're like, shut the fuck up.
Because they play like almost every day.
They play incredibly frequently.
And I'm there.
I just showed up.
I was like, oh, hey, isn't this the same rank as you guys?
But like, honestly, I think it's based off of your win percentage.
Because I play, I don't play ranked.
And I play with my friends.
So, like, I obviously don't perform the best, but my friends do.
And then, they're like, how the fuck are you the same rank as us?
You know what I mean?
Because like my stats, my stats are so bad.
They're so bad.
But I thought it was really funny.
I was like, hey guys, look at us.
We're the same.
We're the same, guys.
Apparently, it's like platter diamond in Deadlock, which is funny.
And Marvel Rivals is coming out next week.
I'm excited to play that next week.
That's really, that's really the life update.
That was like my way to stall Silent Hill 2.
Because we're gonna like, we're gonna fucking die before we finish this game.
You're all gonna get married.
You're gonna have kids.
Your kids are gonna have kids.
You're gonna be at the funeral.
And then, and then like, the last thing they play at your funeral is me still playing Silent Hill 2.
Like this is, when will we ever finish the game?
When will we ever finish Silent Hill 2?
I thought it'd be fast.
So that's why I decided to go with Silent Hill 2 instead of returning to Dad of War.
But like, I don't even, some people have already given up on Dad of War.
They're like, we'll never get to see Dad again.
We'll never get to see him again.
At least my children's children will see you finish Silent Hill.
Um, um, oh zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I convinced my brother to be a dragon.
Also, Dad cult?
Where?
I shut it down.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I shut it down.
There should be no other cult than my cult.
I mean, well, to be fair, I think it's better to stay a religion.
Because by being a religion, you get to have tax breaks.
So like, if anything, we should, you can technically register as a religion, as long as you have a place of worship.
So like, maybe eventually, I don't know, somebody will be...
I feel like someday, somebody is gonna make a fucking church for a VTuber.
And it'll be constituted as like, a religion.
Because you can get tax breaks for it.
Um, Nexi, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, let's see.
Oh my gosh, my thing, my donation thing crashed.
I had to reset it.
Uh, oh my god, wait, you disappeared.
Okay, um, Nexi, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Is this the fear of what being a parent feels like?
Why is my oshi like that?
I am like, um, you know like, a D, you know like, girlfriend experience?
I am like, raising a child experience.
Child experience.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Mike, thank you for super chatting so I can solve.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
What will happen first, a heat death of the universe or Doki finishing Silent Hill?
Also, before I, yes, before I finish Silent, not finish, before I play Silent Hill, I'm gonna go, um, grab a cough drop real fast.
I'll be right back, guys.
Don't worry, you can hear me, I didn't mute.
What are you doing here?
I saw, I saw dad crawl out of the bathroom.
I think he was like, abusing the heated floors.
Um, I was like, what are you doing in the bathroom?
Anyway, Alan, thank you for the magenta super, thank you.
Hi Doki, today is my birthday and as a tradition, I have to send a birthday super chat.
I can't believe it's the fourth, fourth, fourth, fourth, fourth birthday with you.
And the drag, I'm like, slowly regressing, um, cause I know I'm playing Silent Hill 2.
But I hope there's even more in the future.
Thank you for everything you do for us, thank you for the magenta super, Alan, thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Alan, happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday to many more!
Um, Skellum, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, got your case last week, did a build so much power so I can run 1990's Sega Genesis.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
And I can watch you.
Alright, let's see.
Uh, expected to be short 14,000 doctors by 2030 with no solution.
Guys, this is what I have to go through.
Oh my god, oh my god, that sounds terrible.
Alan, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
DJ, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I never agreed to a title more than this one.
Oh my god, alright, here we go guys.
Here we go, back to Silent Hill we go.
Today I woke up to like 15 work messages and then I'm, instead of answering them, I'm playing Silent Hill 2.
Sorry.
The people demand that I finish Silent Hill 2, no matter how long.
Alright, let me make sure what is the volume for this game.
Okay, 8.7, there we go.
Yes, it's lagging a little bit.
Oh, it'll tire itself out, there we go, okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, I know where Pastoki left us too, that's the worst part.
The worst part is like, I know where she left us to die.
She saw, she saw what, what was the future and then Jojo'd me.
She, she fucking Jojo'd me.
To be continued and I have to be the continue, that's so fucked up.
That's, that's so fucked up, I'm the to be continued part.
An actual, thank you for the, an actual, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Haven't played the remake but I will not stand by the, the presence, it is the worst level.
It is one, no, the remake for this is the worst level.
It's, it's fucking terrible, like I'm, I'm dreading, I'm dreading it right now.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
No, you played the remake version, you would agree, you would agree this is the worst level.
Oh, I know they're here.
Hello?
Oh.
Oh, I hear him.
Hello?
Can you just come over now?
Oh, I know he's here.
Just go this way.
I'll just go this way.
Oh my god, there's so many miracles in Silent Hill.
What's this?
Oh, it's the medium weight, okay.
Look at all these wheelchairs.
Okay, you can't open doors.
They're legs, how would they open a door?
I'll just close it.
Oh my god, I'll just close the door.
Maybe they can't open it.
Maybe they can't.
Blackfire, thank you with a five, give the ships, thank you.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, do you think he's gonna open my door?
You're just a normal one.
Okay, thank god, okay, he's just a normal one.
He's not the one that spits out.
Oh, I don't have a lot of bullets now.
Is he dead?
I can't remember, I don't remember who I've killed.
I can't remember, it's been way too long.
Who have I killed?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, that's fucked, that's actually fucked.
I don't like that.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh,
fuck, okay.
That's bad.
Guys, how do I heal?
I keep forgetting how to heal.
What's the point of the heal?
I need a doubt before things get worse.
Cause by god, I can, I felt, feel like things are gonna get...
Oh, there the legs are, there she goes.
Oh, there she goes too.
Oh, hey guys.
Oh.
It's 6-0, we're not in Cypher Elite anymore.
I hate this.
I hate this, I know she's here.
Slam!
Okay, it's V, okay.
V.
Oh, what the fuck?
Stop.
In the name of love.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Okay, my pile.
That's fine, I'll take those.
I'll take the pile.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Can I break this wall?
Okay, no I can't.
Alright, I just gotta be sure.
I feel like I'm missing a lot of equipment and stuff, but like, that's okay.
That's okay, I'm already going through it.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where'd you come from?
Oh shit, oh shit, are you fucking- Oh, I hate these guys.
Okay.
That's fine.
We're okay.
I'm not okay, but like, someone's gotta believe, because I know chat, you don't believe in me.
Okay.
Oh, thank god, more ammo.
Alright, ammo time.
Can we break this wall?
Break down the wall!
Oh, what's over there?
What's over here?
I don't remember how to look at my map!
Where's my map?
Okay.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Okay.
Oh my god, there she is.
She's coming for me.
There we go.
I'd rather just headshot her.
Like, she's- oh my god, I don't know what I'm gonna do when she gets close.
The closer she gets, the more power I lose.
Alright.
Let's go this way.
At least I got back some of the ammo I wasted earlier.
Same.
Okay, I didn't grab this.
What the fuck?
We're alive?
We're alive.
Oh, that's the guy I shot- WOAH!
What the fuck?!
That was ba- oh my god, they were gonna rob me!
They were gonna shank me in the corner!
Oh my god!
It was a setup this entire time!
They were ready to shank me in the fucking alleyway!
I knew it.
I'd never go back to London.
Oh, that's somebody.
Where?
They were gonna mug me.
Shank you with what?
They have no hands!
Maybe they have one really sharp leg.
You don't know that.
The remake doesn't- no, don't fucking say that.
I'm like actually so scared.
Like, I can only play this game like at two to three hours every time.
Because I'm so fucking anxious and scared.
Like, don't say that!
It's actually scary!
Oh, I knew it.
I fucking knew it, you fucking- oh, you parasite!
Oh, you fucking- you thought you could get away from me, you fucking spotty!
Alright, we're fine.
Okay, we might as well have got everything now.
Right?
Did we get everything?
Oh, we didn't open this.
Oh, thank god.
Now we have- guys, there's no way we can die.
We have seventeen?
Oh my god.
Okay, armory.
Oh, we have armory!
Where the fuck is the armory though?
There's no way we can die now.
We literally have like- what's this?
In the center of Silent Hill, the town's major tourist attraction.
There's no way.
We literally have seven more so stocked up in fucking meds.
An event containing no details of the ship's disappearance despite an extensive police search.
Not our secret fragment- oh, wait.
Oh shit, it's like- it's like a ghost ship.
The rest of the bottomless lake, their bony hands stretch out toward boats that pass overhead.
Perhaps they reach for their comrades.
Oh shit, ghost ship!
That movie freaked me out because I accidentally saw it on TV when I was really young.
And it was playing on TV when I was like, really incredibly young.
And it was playing that- that infamous scene.
The tripwire scene.
That scene fucked me up.
Not a good user, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Everything will be alright, Doki.
In order to overcome your fears, you must- What if I don't believe in myself?
I just pretend believe.
I don't actually believe.
Where am I?
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We will not perish and beat the- Oh, imagine.
Oh, this has to be the armory!
We get the rifle!
Oh my god, thank god.
Now I'll never use it until a boss fight.
We get the rifle.
Isn't it great?
We get to look at it.
We get to look at the rifle.
Guys, we might never beat it.
GTA 6 is gonna come out and we're still here playing Silent Hill 2.
Yeah, I do.
I should have ammo for this.
No, I should reload it, too.
I have nine bullets.
Alright.
Did I reload my shotgun, too?
Okay, nice.
Oh, this is bad.
I've been wasting- I'm wasting too much.
I almost said light.
I'm wasting way too much ammo.
I hate this level.
I hate this level so fucking much.
I hate this- Oh, I hear- I HEAR- IT'S LIGHT!
IT'S LIGHT!
IT'S LIGHT TIME!
I hate you.
I hate you so much!
WHERE ARE YOU?
Oh my god, I'm fucking gonna step on you.
That's right.
For free.
Okay.
I'm just gonna juice up real fast.
I hate this level so much.
I hate it.
OH MY GOD!
DO THEY RESPAWN?
ARE THEY LAYING EGGS?
Like, what is this?
Guys, I need to know.
Do they respawn?
I actually need to know.
Like, am I wasting my fucking bullets right now?
Oh my god, I'm like, so fucking- WAIT, REALLY?
Are you serious?
They actually respawn.
Oh my god.
I don't remember where the wave thing is.
Where was it?
Was it here?
Oh, it's over here, okay.
Alright.
Okay, what if we put it all on here?
Okay, nevermind.
Doesn't matter.
Okay, nice.
We got the cow.
Where the fuck is the cow?
Oh my god, where's the cow?
The headless serpent.
The hornless ox.
Okay, that's the cow.
They respawn for the three step piece.
They stopped!
When do I know it's eventually?
When do I know it hits eventual levels?
Oh my god.
Oh, there he is.
It's like here.
God, oh my god.
Are you serious?
I can't just- I hate you.
Oh, I've never hated a fucking monster like you.
Oh, where are you?
Oh, there's several now!
I need to turn on the lights.
Oh my god!
They're repopulating!
They're actually repopulating!
Oh my god!
They're actually making more!
This is a session right there!
As you guys said, I have a lot of heals.
I don't know about that anymore.
I'm slowly losing more from just these guys.
Oh my god, they're actually repopulating.
They're making more.
Okay, we're going up top.
Oh, I can't calm down.
Oh, you're such a whore!
And you are!
The thing is, I know you're a whore.
Are you?
What are you?
Oh!
I'm not doing okay right now.
I am fucking- Oh!
Where am I?
I know- Oh my god, bro.
Guys, guys.
I had 17.
I had- She disappeared!
How did he disappear?
Why?
He actually disappeared!
Wait, where did he go?
Where did he- I shot him and he TP'd away!
Oh no.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Ah!
Oh my god!
They just- Oh my god!
Why?
I had so much meds before!
Bro!
These guys suck!
They suck so much!
Not in like a good way!
Oh my god.
I hate them.
No,
I do not sound like I'm having fun right now with these fuckers.
Oh my god.
I self-blocked D.
Where is self-block D?
Okay, it's over there.
Alright.
It's over there.
I need to find the key for self-block 4.
Destruction reported.
C-140 yelling about C-777 haunting him.
Claim bars can't hold him.
Okay.
Bathroom door is barred from inside.
Efforts made to get them open.
We don't hear anything from the other side.
Okay, that does not sound promising!
I'm gonna use my bullets.
I don't care anymore.
I don't care.
I'm not using my fucking hands anymore.
It's over.
No more hands.
I don't care.
I don't care about ammo.
These guys really, really suck.
I don't care anymore.
We're gonna use our hands.
Where does this go?
We're not gonna use our hands anymore.
We're gonna use our fucking...
Wait, where does this go?
Oh, that's for the boar.
We use our gun.
I wasted so many meds for this particular area.
For just this area, too.
That's the worst part.
Okay, we're not that crazy.
We're not gonna use our fucking...
Just in case he's gonna explode.
Spider lady?
Spider man?
Are you there?
Any spider ladies near me?
Any single spider ladies in my area?
Please.
Please don't do this to me.
Please just come to me.
I'm just so vulnerable.
Whoa!
Peak...
Peak eating material for your children.
Oh, okay.
Okay, what's this?
The shiv key?
The fuck am I gonna do with a shiv key?
Shame you didn't find it.
Shouldn't you know this place better than I do?
Now it's too late.
I'm going for a walk.
Find what?
I'm just...
My mission isn't to find anything.
I'm just trying to survive.
What am I even trying to find anymore?
What do I do with a shiv key?
Guys, what do I do?
What is a shiv key?
Okay.
Hello?
I knew it.
I knew you were...
Oh, you're just gonna crawl up, you fucker.
You just...
Oh, just cause you can just walk?
Oh my god, I hate you!
I hate you!
I hate you so much!
He actually jumped down from above!
Oh, just to fuck with me.
And it worked.
And it fucking worked.
Oh my god, saw someone walking past lights out again.
Which one of everyone that you... of you that was do I need to remind you that you must never leave your post without...
Oh my god, I knew it.
I fucking... I heard you.
I... Oh, I knew it!
I fucking...
Yes, okay, back to read.
Well, guess we'll never know what happens in that note.
I heard that.
I heard him.
I fucking...
I knew you were gonna come back.
I knew it.
What the fuck is he doing?
Oh, I see you!
I fucking see you!
Oh...
I see him right over there.
Oh, come on.
How much ammo do I have left on my hand?
Okay, it's doable.
It's doable.
He's up there!
He's like up there!
I see him!
Maybe he'll come back down because he'll think it's night time.
Is he in the cup?
He's not.
He's just gonna stay up there like the little bitch he is.
What the fuck?
That's fucking right.
I would shoot a spider.
I would 100% shoot a spider.
Alright.
We got this area.
Okay.
Now we're here.
Oh, he's coming.
I know he is.
The bars, the walls.
They can't hold him.
He'll get in!
I still have time.
I can make it almost through.
But he's close.
I can feel it.
He's coming to finish it.
What the fuck is wrong with him?
Oh no, he's going to schizo.
Oh, just like me.
And these walls.
These fucking walls.
I hear him.
I hear them.
Oh my god, the spiders.
The spiders are gonna come here and give me a voice.
Okay, I gotta smash these guys just in case.
I'm so paranoid.
Are they in the bathroom?
I knew it.
I was like, excuse me.
I was using that.
I'm sorry, ma'am.
I'm so sorry, ma'am.
What?
Where did you come from?
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm in the stupid quarters.
Oh, thank god.
Oh my god, I wish it was just nurses.
I miss the nurses, not gonna lie.
Bring them back.
Bring the nurses back.
The nurses were easier.
The nurses were 100% easier than this hellhole I'm in right now.
They won't save you.
Please, I'm just a little guy.
I didn't just...
Oh, nurses are so much easier and nicer to me.
Nurses are so nice to me, guys.
I miss that.
I've never used so many meds as now.
I've been like really good with my med situation and now I think I'm gonna overdose on it.
I told you, I told you.
They don't listen.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
More ammo.
We need it.
What's that sound?
Wait, what's that sound?
Why was there banging?
What?
Hello?
I'm gonna wait until...
What's that sound?
I...
I don't know what that sound was.
And my light is almost gone.
I have to wait until...
Hello?
Knock-knock?
Oh...
Please...
I just wanna leave Silent Hill.
I don't care about my dead wife anyway.
I don't care about her anymore.
It wasn't that.
It wasn't that good enough for me to die in this town.
Oh, I don't like this.
There's dead things already here.
Why are there dead bodies everywhere?
Is he here?
Oh, I don't like that.
I think he's here.
I think cooler me is here.
The cooler version of me.
The guy I wish I was.
The guy she told you not to worry about.
I think it's him.
Oh, it's giving me so much ammo.
That's never a good sign.
Oh, this is never a good sign.
Guys, is he killable?
Is he gonna show up?
And is he killable?
Is he killable?
Or is it...
Okay.
I swear if I try to kill him and you're like why are you wasting ammo, dude?
I swear to god, I'm not.
I'm not okay.
Okay, it's time to stick your hand in the wall.
Stick your hand in the wall.
James, it's time.
It's your favorite time of the year.
It's okay, it's like a little massage with the little bugs with us.
Oh, here he is.
Wait, what?
What?!
Wait, what?!
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Okay, we're just gonna get these guys out of the way.
Oh, so like we're fine.
Oh, we are not fine!
Okay, nevermind.
Will he crawl over?
Oh, shit!
Guys!
Guys, one at a fucking time!
Oh, shit!
Not the women!
There's too many!
Oh, shit!
Too many women!
Oh, god.
Oh, god, please don't explode on me.
Too many women.
Guys, I can't handle there's too many!
One isn't more than enough!
Monogamy!
Let's go!
Okay.
Just in case.
Oh!
Alright, we're fine.
Okay, we're okay.
We're not okay.
Oh, we're not okay.
Okay.
Don't have a lot of ammo left!
Hello?
Alright.
Too many women!
It's a skill issue.
Okay, this way.
I thought that was something else.
How do I get back down?
I don't remember.
Oh, there was another thing I can open over here.
I remember now.
Should be another gate.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, what?
Oh!
There we go.
I make my own holes!
That's right!
Okay.
Oh my god, thank you.
Please, I need ammo.
I don't need this.
I need ammo.
Can I open this now?
Okay, I can't.
Okay.
That's fine.
We're not doing too well, though.
We are- We're not doing- We're running out of ammo!
We're running out of very- I've used so many on the spiders!
I've saved so many, but I've also used so many on just the spiders alone.
You don't understand.
You don't understand the pain of my existence right now.
Okay.
Save.
Alright.
We're okay.
Robo, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
This is my very first super chat to you, Doki!
I'm also glad I'm watching a streamer who remembers to reload before fights.
It depends.
I'm- I'm very scared, so I'm always reloading.
Okay.
If I put it here...
No?
You mean this?
Oh, that's way too heavy.
Maybe I can open the boar room now, though.
Yay!
Okay, we can open the boar room.
Alright.
No, it doesn't waste ammo.
It's not that realistic.
Thank God.
Thank fucking God.
Okay.
Back to hell I go.
Alright, where's the boar head?
We're in this ox.
Wait, did I not finish the- Oh no, it doesn't tell you when you finish a room.
It like crosses it out, but it doesn't, so like, I just have to remember if I've been there or not.
Okay, so I got the boar now.
Two more.
Two more left of the hell.
Okay, the boar is this way.
Oh, maybe I'll finally leave the jail.
Maybe I'll finally leave this God-forsaken world.
Okay.
Nope, I have to go straight.
Alright, let's go straight.
Let's go!
Oop, I hear something to my right!
Wonder what that could be.
Oh, it's not the spider, that's fine.
It's just that guy.
Um, no, I feel like he's gonna spit on me, so I'm just gonna...
Okay, I know I'm not supposed to waste ammo, but I really don't want to kill him, so you don't understand!
Incident at the infirmary.
Assaulted medical staff attempted to steal medication.
Rumors of disease spreading among the prisoners.
Guys, all I'm saying is- whoa!
Okay, anyway, guys, all I'm saying is that we are in a prison.
Where are the ammo from the prison guards?
I know they should be packing right about now.
Prison guards, where did you- Whoa!
Oh my god, that's- I saw it too!
I saw her!
I knew she was there!
Oh, I saw her too.
Why did you keep your ammo in the library?
What are you gonna do, shoot the books?
Oh, Always prepared.
Okay.
What shortcut is this?
Oh, it's this shortcut, okay.
Knowledge is power, Doki.
Oh my god, nine bullets in a dream.
I remember when I used to have 40 bullets.
This area does not give you any ammo!
That's so fucked.
If anybody prisons should be worried, they'd give me the most ammo.
So fucked.
I think this level is the one that's like actually messed me up the most.
It was smooth sailing in all the other levels, it was such smooth sailing.
Like, I was not doing as bad as the other ones.
Oh, there you are.
Oh, what?
How the
- Like, what, you poked me and I died?
Like, like, I'm sorry.
You fucking poked my fucking ass apparently.
Can I read any of this?
Oh, guards think we're lepers now.
Don't know why, but they stay away.
I don't complain.
That was not fair.
That was actually not fair.
Oh, thank god.
That's what I needed.
I have six bullets.
I'm not gonna use my shotgun.
Okay, that's a bug.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, there's a nurse right here.
Initial- Where did she go?
Is she gonna walk all the way from here?
She didn't even see me.
Where's she gonna walk to?
Oh, what the fuck?
You didn't even know I was here!
No, oh no.
Oh no, I'm sorry.
Oh wait, oh no, there's a- this is it.
I have 33!
Guys, I have 33 shotgun bullets.
Oh my god.
Is this gonna be the shot that ends Silent Hill?
Thank you for the super chat paladins.
Thank you.
Why the fuck do I have 33 shotguns?
Where is my handgun ammo?
I don't need more meds, please.
I don't need more.
Doctor, please.
If you keep giving me more meds, I'm gonna fucking die.
What?
What the fuck?
Who was that?
Hello?
Oh, save point.
I'm okay now.
Yeah, that that did not sound safe.
That, I feel like I- aww.
That did not feel safe.
It does not give me joy.
Hello?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Alright, there's TV.
Break time!
Break time?
Is it break hours?
Please.
Oh, thank god.
Two more handgun ammo.
Not all is lost.
Light up!
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Emergency medical examination report.
Report conclusions are incorrect.
The prisoners are sick.
Examinations are to be repeated until their condition is properly diagnosed.
Use more invasive methods?
Bro, just tell them to spin on something and then see what it is.
What do you mean invasive?
What does that mean?
Hello?
Is there any loot?
Oh, thank god.
It's on TV.
Oh.
Now no one can be entertained.
Napo!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh god, okay.
Oh, it's your very first super chat!
Thank you for your very first super chat, too!
Thank you, thank you!
What's this?
Oh, it's from the first Silent Hill, too.
Stand proud, Doki.
You're strong.
I'm happy to give you my first super.
Oh my god.
Thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is where I was.
Sorry, my voice cracked.
I was going through puberty.
You know those moments when you're like...
When you're going through puberty and your voice starts cracking?
It's one of those days.
Okay, you each get like one...
Three shots.
If you don't die by the third shot, I start...
I start crawling.
I start swinging.
Thank you.
That's the third puberty this week.
Puberty is a long-term thing.
Puberty doesn't just stop.
That's what I'm saying.
Immediate disciplinary actions.
Where the fuck is my ammo?
Where did my ammo go?
Alright.
One.
Two.
Three.
Swing.
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I am so sorry.
She's a shanker.
Like, why does she take three shots?
Okay, the shanker's gone.
Oh my god.
I'm reminded of London every time I see her.
Alright.
Off we go.
Oh, they're finally giving me more ammo.
More handgun ammo.
Oh.
That's good.
We got the upper floor key.
Where was that for?
Where
was that for?
They should just let all the prisoners go.
That's what they did.
During COVID.
Isn't that what they did during COVID?
They were like, you're all free now.
To be fair, that's like, really fucked up.
But like...
Yeah!
I remember reading about that.
Didn't they, like, when COVID happened?
Not all of them, but like, some were released from jail.
Cause they were like, oh yeah, like, it's too cramped.
I'm pretty sure...
What country?
Think what country that would happen to.
I remember reading an article about that.
Because like, it was basically like, they were scared of COVID, so they like, released some of the inmates that were not like, jailed for like, really bad reasons.
Yeah, for like, minor crime.
Definitely not in America.
And then like, for years, some of them were apparently like, lepers or whatever, just released.
No!
Canada, moment!
Guys, it was not Canada.
Guys, I hate it to break it to you guys.
It's somewhere in NA, and it was not Canada.
Isn't that fucking crazy?
They're like, you're free now.
Whoa!
Where were you heading?
Making my way downtown.
Whoa!
Where were you heading, ma'am?
You're walking fast.
Why were you walking so fast?
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
I don't wanna deal with that.
I'm gonna go back upstairs.
Is that a doctor?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Check my corners, left and right, before you cross the street.
And you might get ammo on the way.
Oh, fucking hell.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Sick, sick, sick, sick, sick, sick.
Sick.
Oh, shit.
I did it.
I spelled sick.
I was definitely typing that.
Easiest puzzle of my life.
What an easy puzzle.
Guys, I didn't realize A is S, guys.
Paul, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
How the fuck do we get to the other side?
There was a spider on the other side.
Is there a wall I can break?
Oh, he was outside.
Oh, fuck.
Burrito, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
In some places, they made it so no one got bailed.
So people were booked and let go immediately.
That does not sound very...
Then why get arrested?
I guess you get...
I guess you're put on the record?
Because I'm like thinking, what's the point?
You might as well not arrest people at that point.
I hear him.
He's outside.
Oh, never mind.
He wants to come in.
Okay, alright.
Get down.
Oh, true quotes.
I heard about that.
Yeah.
Get over here.
Oh, that's the worst.
You're the worst.
You're actually the worst.
I know you're upset.
I know you crawled all the way up there.
I know you're up there too.
That's...
Oh, I fucking hate you.
This is the worst part.
I know he's up there.
I can't go through this door.
Wait, then what's the point of having a shortcut here?
Where's the other exit?
I don't remember.
Is it like here?
Changing room.
Shower.
Guards room.
Which way is the other exit?
Here?
Oh, that's the other safe point.
There was another exit here.
I fucking knew it.
Oh, why are you running away?
It's because I killed your brothers and sisters?
That's right!
Fuck you!
Alright, alright.
We got this guy out of the way.
There's more!
I hate them.
I hate them so much.
What was the point of going here?
Like, how do I leave?
How the fuck do I leave?
Get out of here!
There's...
I'm getting out of here.
I'm going back this way.
Fuck this.
I'm going to go the long way.
You can't do that, dude.
It feels like Ikea.
It actually feels like Ikea right now.
I'm trying to figure out how to get out of here.
I guess...
Block D?
Is Block D a way to get out?
Block D.
I...
Where?
How did you...
Where do you keep making babies?
Okay.
Okay, we're going to go through Block D.
I stood still for one second.
One goddamn second.
Oh my god.
The fucking spider gangbang that's repopulating the population.
I have to stop it.
Oh my god, we figured it out.
We finally figured it out.
I hear so many of them outside right now.
Repopulating as I speak.
I fucking knew it.
I don't care if I used up...
I don't care.
I have four bullets.
I'm instating a ban.
It's time.
No more woohoo.
We gotta control this population.
Okay, and then the dove is the last one.
Okay.
Woohoo, time is over.
They have nothing to do anymore.
They have nothing to do.
Doki.
Doki, how could you say that?
What else do they have?
This is funny.
Oh no, I see him too.
You think I don't see you?
Just like...
That's my woohoo partner for the night.
How dare you.
We're gonna woohoo tonight.
Please at least let me look at the fucking map first before you get it down.
If I have no fun here, nobody can have fun in this town.
Wait, what?
Oh shit.
Now I'm in horny jail.
Oh no.
Oh no, they're trapped and there was them.
Why meds?
Why can't you just give the prisoner ammo?
I'm trapped in there with them guys.
Oh no, what do I do?
What do I do?
I'm trapped in there with the fucking freaks.
Freaks.
Woman in flight.
Oh, that's beautiful.
436 people on a reciter.
That's beautiful.
Burning man.
Oh, that is not as beautiful.
Things were very cheery and then he...
And then he burned everything down.
I saw him run through.
My one bullet to make it count.
I mean, it sort of counted.
Like, I think I hit him.
What?
Where did you go?
I can't see!
Oh my god.
The fuck is this room?
Like, what do you...
Oh, I guess this is the padded rooms.
But, like...
Not padded.
Can I open these?
Oh, I can.
Lord Kuros is singing in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you want prison rice?
Because I'm pretty sure this is how you get prison rice.
I mean, they're already beating me up.
What worse can they do now?
Just a small town girl.
Living in a lonely world.
What was your purpose?
Why?
Why were you...
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
I don't know why he just walked over.
But that's okay.
He just casually scrolled past me.
She was just having her morning jog.
Why'd you do that?
That's fucked up, Doki.
She just...
It's just a normal jog.
Can I go up?
Alright.
How the fuck would I be upstairs?
What's the shortcut?
Oh my god.
It's back here.
It's here.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking...
I'm leaving.
This is where they repopulate.
This is the repopulation zone.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Where did this guy come from?
Please call it anything else.
The woohoo chamber.
Thank you, Entire, for the wonderful name suggestion.
Woohoo!
Okay.
I have no more light ammo.
Can I open this?
Oh my god.
Why is it always meds?
Does it not see the zero bullets in my inventory?
Tori!
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
Get down!
Sims can no longer woohoo with pyramid head.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got it.
No, I can't shoot anymore.
I have to fucking brawl it out.
They took away my ammo.
I have 42 fucking shotgun bullets.
What the fuck?
There were two over there?
How is there two?
Oh!
Alright.
That's fine.
Open this.
Nice.
Nothing.
Just books.
Oh, sweet, wonderful books.
That's what I needed.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bro said woohoo chamber.
All I heard was the other chamber.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, coward.
Oh, no.
Still more shotgun.
Okay.
F6 is over there.
Alright, how many monsters am I gonna unleash by pressing this button?
Time to find out.
Might as well do F5 as well.
Okay.
F5.
Okay, F6 time.
I'm sorry, I'm so sorry.
I couldn't let them take you and now you're...
you're still there, aren't you?
Oh, no.
Oh.
Okay, we got the last wave.
Hello?
I need a second.
Because I don't think they're happy about the woohoo band, guys.
I don't.
I don't think they're happy about the woohoo band, guys.
I think they're...
I think they're really mad.
I think...
I think they're...
Oh.
Oh, you can run out of ammo in this game?
I was found the game too much, I had almost 200 pistol ammo at that point.
As I think...
I think they're really mad about the band.
Guys, I don't wanna leave.
Hello?
Oh.
Guys, I...
I'm not happy.
I'm back.
Oh, Batark, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
You have to understand.
I...
Guys, it hurts me as well, guys.
You know, I don't wanna take away your joy.
You guys know that, right?
Oh, no.
I can't light things up anymore.
What?
Oh, my God.
Okay, I was like, why is it moving away?
Okay.
Oh.
Guys, guys, I didn't wanna take away your joy, but my hands were tied.
Guys, you know that, right?
My hands were tied.
Everybody, I'm told.
I didn't wanna take away your joy.
Guys, like, I'm not that person.
I would never...
Oh, wait.
Maybe if I do that.
Maybe like...
Trial and error, everybody.
Trial and error.
It will eventually work.
Maybe I should put it on this side and then...
Okay, but what if I put this and then put it over here?
Okay, but not that.
Okay, but what if I put this?
Okay, that's way too heavy.
Bam!
So easy.
Execution lever.
Oh, no.
This feels like a boss fight.
Oh, this feels like a boss fight.
Oh, my God.
What is this?
It's time to...
It's time to super...
Superman.
It's time to crank that soldier boy.
Crank that soldier boy.
Wait, what does it say?
For your grace, I do not plead.
For the flames, I did set free.
Sisters shriek and children cry.
No one made it out alive.
The fuck?
Okay.
I have to read?
This?
Assume it's that.
Okay.
The wealth of others I did take.
The seven statues I did break.
And yet my deeds I don't regret.
I had my reason.
That is that.
The fuck?
Okay.
Okay, it's not that.
No, it can't be that.
But it can't be that either.
Oh, this one.
That has to be two.
Oh, shit.
No, that's two.
I didn't realize.
I thought when you get it right, it'll just like...
Okay, I took the child.
You were quite right.
Carried her off into night.
She did not scream.
She did not bawl.
I was her father after all.
Which one's about the child?
There you go.
My only daughter.
Joy of days.
They wanted to take you away.
Hush, little baby.
Maybe he's still.
If I can't have you, no one.
God, that's so dark.
Once the sun has ceased its rain, I cut through the rusty chain.
Pushed the door and snuck within.
Filled my pockets to the brim.
This one.
I departed with great haste, leaving not a single trace.
Ever faithful to my creed, all is right, which feeds my greed.
Mommy dearest, mommy sweet, your love for me was so deep.
Why, oh why, you shouted out when my night pierced through your...
That doesn't even rhyme.
Out heart?
Sweet deep?
The fuck?
That's not a rhyme.
Everything else rhymed.
Wait, what?
Okay, this one, that's definitely this.
Oh, it's not poems?
Well, anyway.
There you go.
I did it.
I didn't do it?
Is that it?
No more will I raise my ass to truth.
I see all I taste.
What the fuck?
Which one did I fuck up?
Pull ye but once on the ropes, choose the ones justified from among the damned.
Seek out their tales, think upon each sin, or let blind fate choose.
Let the judgment begin.
Oh, I have to pick a sin!
Oh no, they're all pretty bad.
I guess the first one?
The first one?
I say the first one, number one.
Everyone else committed to the crime.
I feel like the first one was the least worst.
Then a lot of orphans died, so like, no one made it out alive.
I mean, like, that's just money.
Four is literally money.
I guess.
Like, he just took money, it's not that bad.
Yeah, four, like, stole.
Like, he stole one thing.
Um, I guess four?
How do I pick?
I choose four.
How do I pick it?
I mean, one is more...
I can't remove it.
It won't let me remove.
Yeah, it won't let me remove it.
How do I remove it?
There's a noose?
Oh, shit!
Fuck, okay, I'm gonna save.
I didn't realize there was stuff behind me!
Okay.
Alright, well...
One was justified, because he was trying to, you know...
I mean, like, out of all of them, it's like, which one is the most justified?
I guess one is the most justified, because he was trying to save them.
And then, like...
And then, I guess that...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Because, like, I feel like four is not really justified.
He just did it for, like, money reasons.
And then...
It's either one or six, I feel.
Six was, like, self-defense.
Yeah, it's either one or six.
Um...
I'll do one.
It's okay, it's just...
Did I live?
Where am I?
Did I do it?
Did...
Was it correct?
I don't know.
I can't tell if it's a good thing or a bad thing.
Don't worry, the...
It's alive.
Wait, I can't...
Oh, my God.
Down I go, I guess.
I guess down I go.
Take the jump!
Don't worry, the mask will cushion the drop.
Girl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
One of my joys watching you play horror games.
Do a flip!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
Now where am I?
Oh, back to black mode.
Let's go.
To be fair, it's the least of his worries, black mode.
That's a slow death versus instantaneous.
Alright, down you go again!
Down is up, as they all say.
The hole is your goal.
It's made for you, James.
Alright, now where am I?
Oh, shit, ammo.
Sweet, that was a good hole.
Look at that, James!
You chose a good hole!
Oh!
Oh, fuck, I'm like a little mouse.
No!
I'm in a mouse trap!
They baited me with cheese!
Like a fucking rat!
I've been caught like a rat!
They knew I was desperate!
I just wanted my cheese!
Oh, no.
How did they know?
How did they know I wanted cheese?
Oh, I'm in the labyrinth.
Wait, that does not sound like a good time.
Hello?
I got handgun ammo now.
You got the rat!
The rat has been caught!
You can let me go now!
You know when you catch a rat and then you let it go outside into the wild?
Angela?
Angela, is everything okay?
Oh?
Oh, I don't like this place, Angela.
Oh, look, more meds.
More meds.
I think it's trying to tell me something by giving me all these meds.
Is it trying to tell me to take my meds?
I don't understand.
I think the game handing me 17 fucking medication bottles is trying to tell me something.
I'll take my meds eventually, okay?
I just don't want the voices to disappear.
Angela?
Angela, it's me.
It's me!
See my crazy dog head?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
Oh, shit!
This is what this was for.
Oh, shit, that's not what I meant to do!
Oh, fuck!
Corridor!
Oh, I can!
I was gonna say!
Okay, that's good.
That's not good!
Where'd he go?
Hello?
Oh, hey, ammo.
Got it.
I just realized that's not a pink thing, guys.
Oh, no!
Knock, knock.
PT time?
Angela?
Angela, I did it!
Angela, are you okay?
Okay, god, okay!
Am I wasting ammo by shooting him?
I need to know this now.
Okay, I'm not.
Okay, that's good.
Alright, that's good to know.
Alright, shooting's fine.
I just have to be sure.
Angela, don't worry, Angela!
It's not...
Not him!
Oh...
Oh, that's her hidey corner.
Oh, that's so sad.
Oh, that's her safe corner.
Safe space.
Okay.
Is there any sure ammo anywhere?
Let's go.
Huh?
What?
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Oh, oh, oh!
Okay, goodbye!
Goodbye!
Wait, did he leave?
Oh, nice.
Nice, he left.
Angela, I did it, Angela!
He's gone forever for real this time!
For real, Angela!
He's definitely gone now!
Okay.
Oh, this is a safe space area.
Can
I go back into the safe space?
No?
Oh.
Oh, oh!
How are you still alive?!
Bullets!
Oh, shit!
Damn, suck!
Please!
Who are you?!
Holy fuck!
I had 40 shotgun ammo!
I had to melee the door!
Holy shit!
Where do I go at this point?
Oh, good.
He's actually pretty- Oh my god, I'm gonna start meleeing.
I don't wanna waste more ammo anymore.
He's way too tanky.
I already wasted way too much shotgun ammo for this guy.
Hello?
Oh, this way.
Oh, I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Oh, it's this way.
I'm sorry for freaking all your TVs, but who uses TVs anymore anyway, you know?
Like, I'm just doing you a service.
Nobody uses TVs anyway, anyway.
I think you're a bad person.
Oh my god.
Yeah?
You think I'm special?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, that's flesh.
Oh, that's flesh right there.
Oh.
Oh!
It's- Oh!
Oh, it's- Yep.
Yep.
That's right!
I'm ready to fucking brawl!
Come at me!
That's right!
Better smash!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
You're so slow!
Oh!
That's right!
Fighting time!
No more ammo wasted!
I'm gonna save this for Silent Hill 3!
Saving my bullets for Silent Hill 3!
Let's go!
I already gave you 420 of my ammo!
It's fucking right!
Oh, I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I was just joking!
Oh, he's tired now.
He's like, alright, give me a sec, I gotta get my energy back right there.
I grabbed you once, and now I gotta get my energy back.
Oh my god, get piped!
Being a dork- Wait, where did you come from?
Come on!
I like how he was like, alright, give me like 10 seconds first, I didn't think I was gonna grab you.
Angela with a steel chair!
What?
My wife?
My wife.
Oh!
What?
I just killed your father!
Angela...
I was gonna say something really fucked up, but I restrained myself.
You see?
My wife!
Doki, no.
Not the time.
Huh?
That's not true!
Look, I know you see all these hot, sexy ladies around- monster ladies around me, but that's not true!
They were just thoughts.
Bye!
Goodbye, Angela!
I would never ignore those hot, sexy nurses and like, legs all around me, guys.
I would never.
Oh, there they are.
Jesus fucking Christ.
That was just a painting.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
Oh, I guess I go this way.
Also, Cody, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
It's an Akasupa!
Thank you so much!
Oh, it's this way.
Here's some sandy funds, Doki.
You need it more than I do.
Silent Hill has really done more damage to your sanity.
I know.
This game has fucked me up the most out of all the games I've played.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
I can't believe it.
Oh my God, from 40-something bullets to 18.
I should've- If I knew I could've just piped him, I could've saved so much ammo.
I- I could've saved so much.
Oh.
I just told a labyrinth.
Whoa.
Oh my God, look at those body parts.
Whoa!
Mary, don't look.
Oh.
I'm gonna go.
Oh, I can't.
It's calling me.
You don't understand.
Mary, don't look.
It's calling me.
Don't look, Mary.
I swear, it's not you.
It's just calling me.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think you mixed some text earlier, but...
Angela stabbed his father before coming to Silent Hill, and the app shot Daddy?
Yes, as bad as you think.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, it was pretty bad.
Maria?
Wasn't she dead?
Yeah.
Am I even gonna see her?
Oh, there she is.
James?
James, did you- James, did you not- James, we gave you 17 medication bottles.
Did you not take any?
Wait, my popcorn.
It was just a prank.
Get pranked.
Oh my god, am I getting gaslighted?
Silly James.
Remember that time in the hotel?
Maria?
You said you took everything.
But you forgot that video tape we made.
A video tape?
James, you fucking freak.
Oh, wow.
I'm not your Mary.
Whoa.
Maria.
I am.
Whoa, Jen!
I'm saying, James, she's her, but alive.
And she can't die, so she'll never get whatever terminal disease she had- Mary had.
Remember the video tape we made together?
I'm real, see?
How did you get underneath my mask?
Oh, she freaky, freaky.
The dog mask stays on.
I have a collar on this mask.
James, we have two more days, James.
Stay strong.
We have two more days.
Stay strong, James.
Resist her.
Don't let the temptations win.
You're almost there, soldier.
The fuck is this?
He just came out of morning chat.
What the
fuck?
Is this a map?
Let's see.
Oh, I did it.
Okay.
I was trying to figure out what the fuck this was, but I did it, I guess.
I was just trying to, like, figure it out.
I don't know how I did it, but it's done.
I don't know what I did.
Oh, the labyrinth.
How long will I be stuck in a maze?
Let's find out.
Let's find out how long I'm gonna be stuck down here.
Is this the door?
Okay, it's this door.
Oh, come on.
Come on!
I just got here!
And now you're giving me bugs?!
Oh my god.
Dyslexic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What are you buying?
Wait, wrong franchise with blonde hair, jacket-wearing protagonist, and a monster invested talent.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Some people just loop around quite a bit here.
Oh, I'm some people.
That's me.
That sounds like something I do.
From a place called the fucking labyrinth?
Yeah.
This directionless bird is already fucking directionless.
Let's give her a maze.
Wouldn't that be funny?
Oh my god!
Are you serious?
Okay.
I'm picking the one with no bugs.
I'm going the easy route.
Alright.
Oh, there's still bugs?!
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I hate this.
I- I hate this room.
I hear some- I fucking hear you.
I knew it!
I knew you were you fucking mouth man!
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I- I heard him.
I heard him walking out the back there.
Oh my god, you fucking freak.
You're such a freak.
Nobody loves you.
Okay, now I'm here.
Okay.
What even is that?
Woah!
Okay.
I expect you too.
Alright, that's fine.
More meds I won't take.
Why give me empty cabinets?
I knew it.
You're supposed to come up when I go around the corner!
There's just ammo.
Thank god.
I gotta move this somewhere.
Okay, here.
Alright.
Boom!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh.
Alright, up we go.
Alright.
Alright, James.
It's time to go up.
What?
I don't like that.
Where do I go?
Where am I?
Let's see what's in here.
Let's see what's rotating in this fridge.
Woah!
Nothing!
Is there anything in here?
Is this Asmongold's house before he cleaned it?
Oh, I got lighter gas.
How do I use it though?
What do I do with that though?
Alright, move tab.
Woah, there it is.
Is there a map?
There is.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Okay, that's a suspended cage.
Oh my god.
There is.
I forgot.
They like gave me a fucking...
I forgot they gave me like a magic map.
Thank fucking... Oh my god!
Get out!
I'm leaving!
I'm leaving your house!
Look, I'm gone.
I'm gone.
Are you happy?
I left.
Look, there you go.
This is locked, right?
Yeah.
Oh, he's so freaking mad for no reason.
Okay, I need something to light this up.
So touchy.
So fucking touchy.
Oh.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
I hate this.
I hate the sound.
I think...
I hate the sound the most.
That's...
I think that's what...
The...
The fucking road sounds.
Fucking...
Oh my god.
Yeah, it's so nasty.
I hate it.
I hate it so much.
God, I hate that.
Oh, no!
Are you serious?
Get out!
He likes you!
Leave me alone!
Oh my god, it's this one.
Are you serious?
I can't even see him.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Let me out.
It's back here?
Okay.
Okay, I gotta go straight down.
Okay, this is fucking awkward.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just giving among the sleep vibes.
Good times.
How do I get across though?
The other side?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I hate- Okay, there we go.
Oh, there's somebody.
Oh, there you are.
I knew it.
Oh, you fucking hit back?
How dare you?
Don't you know I'm the main protagonist?
How fucking dare you hit back?
Where am I now?
Okay, there should be something to...
fucking do the lighter...
fuel or something.
I'm like stuttering right now.
This game's got me.
Alright, stick your hand in!
What's the worst that can happen, James?
You stuck your hand in it worse!
Let's go!
Oh, there it is.
We got it.
We got what we needed.
Alright.
Now we got this thing.
Wait, it hit back faster?
What the fuck are you doing over there?
Get your ass out of here.
Oh, fuck you!
I know I shouldn't waste my bullets, but I hate this man.
Nice!
I particularly hate this guy.
I hate him.
I HATE HIM!
Oh my god.
I can't even get out!
I hate him so much.
I hate him.
What the fuck?
Guarded it!
Okay.
That was actual bullshit.
Like, what was I supposed to do in that scenario?
He was literally capping the door!
What the hell?
Oh, there she is.
Well, I can...
There we go.
I was like, I'm pretty sure I can kill her.
What's this key for?
The iron key?
I like how it's like sexy nurses and monsters and then their office job.
Oh, James.
You can never escape the Ouija life.
You're here forever.
That's so silly of you to think you can escape the Ouija life.
I'd rather get out of here.
I don't remember.
Guys, I don't remember.
What was in this door?
Ah!
Okay.
Where am I?
Yeah, I was.
Okay.
Alright, we have everything we needed.
I don't know what my iron key was for, though.
I don't...
I don't remember a locked door anywhere, guys.
I actually don't remember what door was locked.
Guys, what door was it that was locked?
Am I right?
Oh!
That door!
It was this door.
Oh my god, it's time to stick my hat in!
Let's go!
Third time's the charm!
Alright.
Oh.
It's just gonna hurt a little.
C'mon, stick your hat in the acid!
C'mon, do it, James!
Stick your hat in the acid!
Stick it in!
Serious?
Oh, I have to, like, let it go.
Let it go.
Okay, that should be fine now.
Alright, stick your hat in!
Let's go!
Okay, nice, we got everything then.
That should be everything we need.
Alright, let's save it up.
Wait, I need to combine them first.
Oh, I forgot.
Okay.
Uh...
Nice.
What's in that body?
What's in it?
It's like a Christmas present!
Christmas is cancelled.
Am I gonna jump into another hole?
Oh my...
Okay.
Okay, James.
I guess we're gonna jump into the other hole that we created.
Alright, down we go.
We know we have to jump down, James!
Time for another hole.
Woah...
When is there...
When is one hole too many?
Woah...
Okay.
We're still in the labyrinth?
Oh, we're back here!
Wait, what was the point?
I didn't get anything important from that!
Wait, what?
Why?
I guess the body?
Okay, I still can.
I guess the cube changed.
Yeah.
I was gonna say, like...
I just felt like I didn't get anything important from that at all.
Oh, I did it again.
Yay, brute force!
Let's go!
Alright, down or up?
I'll go up.
I feel safer.
I guess I go down.
It doesn't matter what they think.
No?
Do I have to rotate the cube again?
Another entrance here?
Oh, there's nothing!
You think I can jump?
Oh, there's over here!
Okay.
Let's see this exit.
It's a red door now.
I...
I'm so mad.
It's you.
It's fucking you.
It's always you.
Oh, my God.
When will you leave me alone?
We're leaving this for future Doki.
I can't.
I'm sorry.
I saw the spiders and I can't.
I can't.
I saw the spiders.
I can't deal.
I thought they were gone.
I didn't realize they were still here.
I thought they would leave me alone.
Why are they still here?
Then you'll...
Then future Doki will get to the good part.
Future Doki will get to the good part.
Alright.
Guys.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
I need to know.
How much more of the game do we have left?
Don't judge it by my time.
Don't judge it by the amount of time.
How long it's taking me.
I need to know.
How...
How much longer, like hours wise, do I have left?
Okay.
The next playthrough...
I promise you guys this.
The next playthrough of Silent Hill...
We finish it.
We...
We actually finish it.
We're gonna...
This will be the day.
Just remember.
Yes.
Part 7 is when we finally beat Silent Hill 2.
Future Doki is gonna kick your ass.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Future Doki will...
Will handle it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is it out?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, is it out now?
Oh my god, it is!
Oh yeah!
The merch is out now.
Yeah.
Yes, and the postcard.
We have to sign there.
But yes.
The Phantom Thief...
Merch is now out.
We have t-shirts, keychain, lanyard, concert towel, penlight, postcards, ticket, and a tote bag.
I'll post a link right here.
And also another thing to show is GamerStuffs, guys.
GamerStuffs, yay!
Let's see.
But yes, if you support me, we have GamerStuffs too.
There's so much stuff.
And then there's Hyatt.
There's the Hyatt keycaps.
And the...
The keycaps and the PC case and everything.
Oh my god, there's so much stuff to show.
There's so much stuff to show.
I'm so overwhelmed.
I'm not used to showing so much for things.
Oh my god.
Okay, but next week, we'll finish Silent Hill 2.
I promise you guys.
Next week, we'll fucking finish Silent Hill 2.
Guys, I promise you, it will be done for real this time.
I swear.
I fucking swear.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna rest my voice.
I'm tired.
Thank you all for coming.
PapaSmart, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is this a real promise or a top 500?
I promise.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fine, I promise you guys this.
Next week, we're finally gonna see the ending of Silent Hill 2.
You do not have to wait for your kids' kids to see the ending.
You will be alive to watch the ending of Silent Hill 2.
This is your day.
Not this today.
Next week is your day.
I just can't do the spiders again right now.
The spiders.
I was already so fucking done.
I was so done.
During the fucking prison, I was so over it.
I couldn't.
After dealing with them in the prison level, I couldn't deal with them anymore.
I've hit my limit.
I've hit my limit with the spider, ladies.
It's just over for me, mentally.
Liam, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
If you finish it now, you never have to play.
Guys, I can't.
I can't.
I can't do it.
I don't know how long it's gonna take me to finish it.
Also, tomorrow's gonna be a long day as well.
I'm trying to make sure I don't overdo it today.
Next week, for sure guys.
For sure.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna rest my voice for next week.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Next week is the custom!
There's some fires I have to put out again today.
I just got like a shit ton of messages regarding it.
I cannot wait for it to be over.
So I don't have to always put out fires.
Anyway, off back to work in the mines.
In the coal mines of this custom.
Anyway, bye-bye everybody.
Bye.
Where's the ending?
Oh, there it is.
Bye.
I was gonna say, where's my ending screen at?
Sorry, yeah.
Tomorrow.
Tomorrow's the custom.
Guys, my mind is so fried.
Bye-bye.